54 of Americans read below a 7th grade
reading level which means that if you're
trying to get people to do stuff you
have to massively simplify it Pascal
said I'm sorry my letter is so long if I
had more time I would have made it
shorter and it's because it takes more
effort to make things simple the amount
of effort that it takes to distill good
stuff down is what makes it valuable
don't think you're dumbing it down think
that you are packaging it in a way that
will communicate to more people and if
you're a silly goose who says well I
don't want to attract any of these dumb
people realize that very smart people
also recognize somebody who
intelligently can distill something down
into simple form so if you want your
thing to reach as many people as
possible make it as simple as possible